georges de rue bonjour militants
culturels et membre du lit un âge où je
vais revoir vous êtes avec nous pour
parler du drapeau de la partie pourquoi
cet objet de discussions sans cesse
revient au devant de la scène la georges
grün aux auditeurs ont entendu cette
campagne de promotion pour le maillot de
la sélection de martinique de football
les matinaux vont disputer la prochaine
coupe des nations de la caraïbe dans 15
jours mais un maillot sans écusson sans
drapeau uniquement le logo de la ligue
de football de martinique
notre pays petit pays sans drapeau avec
peut-être trop de drapeaux georges bru
enfin trop de drapeaux oui c'est à dire
enfin il faut il faudra qu'on arrive à
éclaircir cette question en martinique
il y a trois emblèmes en présence il y a
le drapeau bleu blanc rouge qui est
désolant c'est que le drapeau de l'état
français bon qui la martinique
juridiquement appartient à fait partie
de l'état français donc il est normal
que ce drapeau figure sur le territoire
etc
certaines ne sont pas d'accord mais en
réalité c'est une réalité il y à un
pavillon un pavillon bleu et blanc avec
quatre serpents très contente de
présenter comme le drapeau
martiniquais de la région du pays
martinique
ce qu'il faut savoir il ya beaucoup de
martinique et alors quelle que soit
l'opinion politique 1 quels que soient
leur eau leur engagement politique
beaucoup de martinique ne sont pas
d'accord ne sont plus d'accord avec ça
parce que ce drapeau
c'était celui de la région je dis pas de
rapport à cet avion en réalité cet avion
de la marine marchande qui qui devient
officiel pour la marine marchande
française aux 15e 16e 6 avec un à partir
du 15e siècle et
c'est le mien on y met les cas de
serpents pour signaler qu'en martinique
les na'vi ok acquis qui sont de la
martinique ou qu'ils approchaient
martinique pour signaler qu'en
martinique il y à un serpent venimeux
tribunaux céphale se reconvertir de lens
bon mais il faut savoir que ces navires
qui arrive en martinique
ils sont chargés de entre d'armes et de
marchandises jeudi entre guillemets
puisque c'est ce que c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle ce sont des esclaves
ce sont des des gens qu'on arrache et
d'afrique et qu'on combat mettant en
esclavage en martinique sur les
habitations aussi on le lève donc pour
nous ça ne peut pas être pour beaucoup
de martinique aujourd'hui ça ne peut pas
être ce n'est le drapeau de la
martinique
c'est le drapeau si on peut dire du
queens du crime colonial esclavagiste
qui s'est produit en martinique avec
toutes les horreurs comme ça et puis un
drapeau rouge vert et noir qui ne date
pas forcément des années 60 comme on
pourrait le penser
ce sont des couleurs qui existe depuis
la surrection par exemple 2070 et même
avant alors les les
vous avez raison les couleurs rouge et
noir sont présents sont yoann souquet et
dans la culture martiniquaise depuis
très longtemps depuis la constitution un
des martiniquais en communauté même
depuis l'arrivée des premiers
martiniquais bon je peux donner quelques
exemples on les vit parfois sans s'en le
conscientiser vous allez au carnaval
vous avez le whisky extrêmement présent
vous avez le noir du mercredi des
cendres et le blanc vous avez là là
la couleur verte de la feuille d'eau
colossales dans l'évident électoraux
dans lorsqu on incinère laval
vous avez et les graines les glisser un
kiki pour pourrir les chapeaux pour
qu'il participe à beaucoup de rituels
aussi en martinique donc les couleurs ou
sur des couleurs qui étaient reprises
lors de les votes d'esclaves contre les
colonisateurs français des dc 1660 dans
toute la caraïbe dans toute la caraïbe
les que les couleurs rouge et noir les
couleurs rouge et noir ont été associés
parfois à des mouvements en tout cas à
la résistance culturelle des esclaves
c'est très net nous avons des éléments
maintenant il y a au niveau historique
bon nous ne reprenons pas nous n'avons
pas d'éléments historiques vous dire que
ça a été ce ses couleurs là ont été
associés pendant l'insurrection du sud
ça se dit mais nous n'avons pas les
éléments historiques là dessus euuuuuh
même jean kina etc
l'association un drapeau à notre avis
date de 1963
oui 1963 à l'époque le rouge le noir et
le vert sont avec la sphère de loge m
oui et ce sont des couleurs qui sont ce
sont des bandes horizontales
oui pour les couleurs le rouge en
partant du au deuxième au milieu le noir
et puis ensuite le verre et puis on va
le voir pour ceux qui nous regardent en
vidéo il ya ceux il ya l'arrivée de ce
triangle rouge
ouais ça c'est en 1968 oui parce que
dans un drapeau il n'y a pas seulement
les couleurs il ya la forme
quand il ya la forme des des figures des
couleurs et est ce qu'il ya un débat
là-dessus jusqu'à manifestement pour
tous le choix des couleurs il n'y a plus
de discussion là dessus tout le monde
est d'accord pour rouge vert et noir
soit là mais sur la sur la fiche sur la
forme
ah non il ya des discussions parce que
il ya une discussion même si les
couleurs parce que bon
vous savez comme tout les toutes les
choses qui vont en notre faveur
tous les marqueurs de notre identité et
c'était un bon c'est au combat 1
donc il ya un débat sous les couleurs
bon certaine personne n'a d'ailleurs pas
encore à ses couleurs rouge et noir
comme emblématique de la martinique
pourquoi parce que porter d'abord par
des nationalistes
oui je crois que c'est la principale
raison c'est à dire qu'à l'origine ce
qui associe allons nous avons un
témoignage oral ainsi une première
association parents drapeau dans la
pratique du la soute est très ancienne
en rouge et noir
un témoignage au rebond mais
l'association drapeau se fait en 63 les
affirme jam avec monsieur victor le sort
vous avez 12 emprisonné à fresnes pas
j'ai pas beaucoup qui volait bas et moon
ou bien qu'ils ont décidé à poser leurs
opinions et dans cette souffrance
yvon monsieur victor le sort va faire la
proposition de marc et l'existence
martiniquaise dans ce combat c'était fou
pour signifier notre existence au monde
et il va proposer d'abord que vous avez
dit qui au départ donc et un bandeau au
départ il peut pas les couleurs rouge
vert et jaune et c'est un autre
emprisonnés
militant de loge à monsieur au dos le
désir et du marin qui propose
l'introduction du noir et il faut le
savoir aussi quand il dessine son
drapeau ils disposent des pinceaux de co
couronnais kohail qui lui aussi est
emprisonné c'est damon qui fait
martinique qui fait qu'aujourd'hui s'il
ya cette adhésion est de plus en plus
importante est visible aujourd'hui
beaucoup de personnes se promènent avec
le avec le t-shirt avec les couleurs
rouge noire et verte
il y a quand même cette idée que venant
des milieux nationalistes de ces milieux
nationalistes la de l'époque ça fait pas
d'illusion auprès de la totalité de la
population alors je
j'arrive à votre question parce que ce
que ce que nous disions avant était pas
autant ses couleurs la première
diffusion c'est maintenant harcèlement
ville qui va qui va le diffuser
donc c'est vrai c'est un fait
incontestable le l'organisation en
drapeau de ses couleurs c'est le
mouvement national le mouvement le
mouvement nationaliste avec toutes ses
composantes un autonomistes
indépendantistes et c'est bon en 68
vous avez d'autres militants qui sont
liées à la gemme et et l'association
générale des tirs martinique le
mouvement de libération nationale à
martinique que monsieur notamment alexis
ordinands et monsieur qui cabourg masson
qui peut pas cette organisation avec le
triangle oui bon aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on constate c'est que cette ses
couleurs et ses taux ce drapeau ça
déborde du mouvement national ça touche
maintenant le mouvement identitaire
c'est à dire tous ceux qui sont d'accord
pour dire que nous sommes en tunique et
nous existons et nous devons le
signifier au monde cela au prix d'avant
de plus en plus parce qu'on a besoin
d'eux voilà quelle que soit notre
conception sur la situation actuelle de
la mort dénigrer et sur son avenir
nous pouvons être d'accord et nous
sommes de plus en plus d'accord et nous
constatons tous les jours sur le fait
que nous sommes maudits nikkei chacun
charrues cette identité un cadeau faubel
hachage échappement rachat géant manière
ici on time est une identité
régionale 2 team est une identité
nationale ce n'est pas le plus important
en france qu'on va garder en france
les marine le pen les bleus bleu blanc
rouge et j'enlève le bruit tout le monde
les bleus blancs rouges même s'ils ont
des désaccords sur la situation du pays
donc ce n'est pas un besoin important
mais aujourd'hui vous avez 7 qui gêne
alors pour que tout le monde soit
unanime derrière c -b
je vais plage et peut-être l'idée aux
français qui a rejoint rolland
l'histoire de la france de l'audace
encore de l'audace beaucoup de l'eau
toujours de l'audace
je crois ce qu'il nous faut c'est un
petit peu d'audace il ya beaucoup de
gens nous nous rendons compte qu'ils
adhèrent de plus en plus à cela avec
leur sensibilité propre mais parfois
nous sommes un petit peu paralysés parce
qu'une faute à deux référendums
par exemple dire voulez vous passer de
repos alors référendum sous les formes
en tout cas il faudra en discuter
aujourd'hui ça se discute dans le peuple
ça se discute à la base il faudra
certainement d'en discuter excuse pas
trouvé là tout le monde veut il faudra
certainement discuter officiellement
dans la forme que cela prendra la forme
de alors le débat il touche à des choses
un le valider valider ce qui fait qu'ils
se développent ou bien bon voir s'il ya
des choses à 6,6 il faut autre chose
comment les guyanais se sont mobilisés
derrière leur direction de leur révolte
sociale et celle quoique aujourd'hui la
la population caennaise a validé un plus
discutable mais ainsi avait et tout le
monde l'a banni c'est merci georges bru
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle que vous
êtes militant culturel et membre du
lyannaj rouvert rouge-vert-noir elle
rappelle aussi que vous animez quelques
rencontres quelques discussions autour
de l'histoire de ce drapeau rouge vert
noir merci d'avoir été avec nos bonnes
jambes mais aussi de votre invitation
[Musique]